Pokemon a group of the most unusual  creatures teeming with mystery a protege  of mine has just opened up a new  research facility in Vermillion city I  am professor serese we are dedicated to  uncovering the mysteries of Pokemon in  every region  what is to catch a Pokemon that nobody  has seen before  will you do me the honor of becoming  research fellows at my laboratory three  two one go  [Music]  [Music]  let's stop this show baby - - nope okay  mom is to know the world okay  scorpan is an amazing Pokemon  now on her team I'm really psyched to  learn when our next adventure will be  it's my future and I can hold it in the  palm of my hand let's get some Pokemon  you